All right, so now we're going to look at creating the score and time pickup.
This is going to act as the object that we place inside of the world that the user will
run into and then fire off the different variables or values that we want for our score and our
time.
And to do this, what we're going to do is we're first going to create a new blueprint
based off of Actor.
So let's pop over to the editor now.
We can close whatever blueprints we have open.
We're going to hit control space and then we're going to navigate up to our content
folder.
I'm going to right click and go blueprint class.
And then from the pick parent class, we're going to select our actor and we're going to call
this one BP underscore pickup.
Now, once we've done that, we're going to go ahead and double click on it to open it up.
And we're going to need to do a few things to this.
So first off, we're going to need to put two things on this.
We're going to need to put a sphere collision and some type of static mesh.
And the things are going to work like this.
The sphere collision is what we're going to use to notify our system when the user has
actually collided with this.
And the static mesh is going to represent a visual representation of that.
So we have something to look at in the world.
So let's go ahead and set that up now.
So inside of our pickup, let's go add.
We're going to look for a SPH and we want the sphere collision.
I'm also going to make sure I have it selected when it's added and change its radius here
to 96.
And the other thing that I'm going to do is I'm going to add a cube right here.
And that's just going to add a static mesh.
It's the same as adding a static mesh.
This just does it in one step for us.
So the next thing that we're going to be doing is we're going to take our sphere here.
And one of the cool things about many of the objects that you add inside of blueprints
is if you select them and then you go over to the details panel under events, you're
going to find a whole bunch of different events that you can use to interact with this.
And the event that we want is this on component begin overlap of our sphere collision.
So let's go over to the editor again, select our sphere collision and the details panel.
We're going to come all the way down to the bottom and we're going to look for our on
component begin overlap.
I'm going to press this plus right here.
And what that's going to do is it's going to bring us over to the event graph and boom,
right there we have our on component begin overlap sphere.
Now the next part of this involves us setting up an interface check and then a branch condition
as well as creating some variables.
So let's take a look at our logic before we set everything up.
What we're going to basically doing is when we overlap this, we are going to look at the
other actor.
So what actor overlap this does that actor implement our vehicle interface or BPI vehicle
interface using the branch condition.
If it does, then we are going to add a score and a time to our blueprint interface, which
is going to signal our code that we should increment our time and our score.
So let's do this in the editor now.
So what we're going to do is I'm just going to pull my details panel over a little bit.
So I have a little more real estate.
So we're going to pull off of this and we're going to look for our branch node.
It'd help if I spelled that right.
So there we go branch.
There we go.
And then on our other actor, we're going to pull off and we're going to look for does and right
there under utilities does implement interface.
We're going to under interface select class, we're going to look for our BPI.
And there we go.
There's our BPI vehicle.
So that's the interface that we want.
And then we want to take the return value and plug that in right here to our condition.
Okay.
And the next thing that we're going to do is when this is true, we're going to pull off.
And we're going to look for picked up.
And there we go class BPI vehicle picked up objects message.
And now we need to fill in a few things here.
The other actor is the target here, right?
Because that is the actor that is making that request there.
So we need to make sure that that is filled in and then our score and our time.
Here's a little thing that we can do here.
We want to fill these in, but there's two things that we want to do.
We want to turn these to variables, but we also want to expose those variables so that
they can be modified.
So first off, let's right click on these and go promote to variable and then do the same thing for time.
So now we have a time and a score.
Now to make these variables so that we can modify them when we're placed in the level,
all we need to do is make sure that the instance editable option is set, or we click on this
little eyeball next to the variables to turn them from private variables into public variables.
So let's do that now.
We'll select time and then we'll come here and we'll do instance editable and then for
score, we can just come over here and press this little eyeball and it does the exact same thing.
So if we have both of these selected, we won't be able to do anything.
But again, we can select the time and make it instance editable or public by pressing this eyeball,
or we can select the score and again, instance editable will make this public.
Now once we're done with that, we do need to compile and save.
And the next and last thing we're going to do is we're going to add this destroy actor.
So what this does is basically once we run into this, it should destroy this or remove it from the world.
So let's go ahead and try to add that now.
So we're just going to pull off of our picked up objects.
We're going to look for destroy and there under actor, we have our destroy actor.
So let's just compile and save.
I'm going to close this.
And what should happen now is if I bring up my BP pickup here, we're going to hit run and all the way over there.
Now, I'm not going to see any updates, but I should see it disappear.
So if you see it disappear, that is what we want.
We want it to do that disappearing act for us.
That way we can make sure that everything is working.
And what you're seeing me do here now, just a little pro tip is I was really far away.
I'm going to make it a little easier to test that.
Right. So all I did is it just press play.
When I escaped from play, it brings me back over here to where the play was.
So now I'm in that area in the editor and then I just dragged my actor into there to make it a little bit easier.
So, all right, that is it for this section.
And our next section, we're going to take a look at adding motion graphics and UI to this using UMG or Unreal motion graphics.